okay so Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania is right around the corner and we
have some plot leaks on the film that I
thought we discussed in this video like
Baskin and Robbins we always find out
and after seeing the trailer it seems
like these line up with what we're gonna
be getting in the movie throughout this
video we're going to be breaking them
down and though they should always be
taken with a pinch of salt they could
end up being true so giant spoiler alert
and make sure you subscribe for
brilliant Ant-Man videos like this in
the build up to the movie that was a
rough one and if this is your first time
here welcome to the heavy spoilers show
I'm your host Paul now let's get into
the video
foreign
of this plot leak was posted and full of
Marvel Studio spoilers alongside one
from wakanda Forever from what I've
heard of the premiere of that one it
fully checks out so I thought I'd
reference this with my own sources they
said there's a couple of minor
differences but on the whole It lines up
quite a lot they've given me a bit of
extra info just to clarify certain
things but obviously we won't know if
this is true until we see the movie for
ourselves now there's a couple of major
things I want to talk about based off
the apparent leaks with the first being
what Kang is actually up to according to
the rumors Janet will have come across
Kang decades before when she ended up
being trapped in the quantum realm
apparently they'll show her being chased
by creatures down there and she'll end
up coming face to face with him now
throughout the film we'll learn what
actually happened with Kang and discover
that he had a ship which could travel
across the Multiverse this would allow
him to conquer several realities and it
would also bring him face to face with
his variants this was worn by he who
remains and the movie will very much be
about stopping this coming to fruition
they just wanted him to hang about in
this reality instead of stopping others
Jenna also uses Kang's real name Nathan
and they form a team for some time now
the Pair worked together to fix this
ship but Janna discovered his true plans
and she decided to destroy it this let
them both stuck in the quantum realm and
Kang spent decades plotting his revenge
against her she then fled and Kang has
been hunting for her ever since now
you'll probably remember this line from
the trailer if you watched it 50 times
like I have I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
hey so I was told this is actually said
to Janet and not Scott like how it
appears Kang will promise to get her
home if she can fix his ship and this
will give her the time back with her
daughter hope that she ended up losing
the opening of the movie is meant to
play out very much like how it is in the
trailer it's basically a montage of
Scott reading from his book lookout for
the little guy which we know has been
shown in the d23 trailer this will be
him narrating about his life and we'll
basically see the elements of the
trailer that started off this includes
him walking down the street getting
employee of the century and attending
premieres he also brings up his
friendship with Hulk it talks about
meeting raccoon that could talk now
Scott has hung up the belt according to
this and it says that he just wants to
stay focused on being a dad however we
learned this as him just playing up his
good guy image and that he and his
daughter aren't really that close
probably because she looks completely
different to how she did at the end of
end game hey
at the heart of this movie it will be
about them trying to reconnect and for
school it'll come to realize as things
more important than being a celebrity
family apparently Scott will get a call
from prison and he'll have to bail
Cassie out this Murrs him being in jail
in the first movie and he doesn't really
want that life for her similar to him
she's basically doing a Robin Hood and
stealing from the rich in order to help
out the poor it's a Cool Crime I'll
admit and the lab scene is meant to
happen pretty early on with a device
sucking everyone into the quantum realm
there's a massive civilization down
there that we've not been privy to
before and this is of course shown in
the trailer The League says that they
serve giant stingrays and as it was
posted before the teaser with details
like this it makes me think it's pretty
spot-on now the group will be separated
in the quantum realm with Scott and
Cassie being up on their own during this
time Janet and Hank will meet Bill
Murray's krylar who had a thing with
Janet while she was down there she was
cheating my manhank states are loyal he
got called Hank the wank which isn't
gonna go down well with the family might
have made that bit of about Hank the
wank or I might have just exposed
foggy's whole game anyway they also bump
into Murdoch which is revealed to be
Darren cross he was sucked down there
after the first film and you just Scott
messing up his body he's completely out
of proportion Murdoch initially starts
off as a villain but he actually ends up
changing sides now you might remember a
couple of weeks ago that William Jackson
Harper was announced as being in the
film and many thought that he might be
Reed Richards however he's apparently
just the leader of the quantum people
and he has the ability to read minds now
this video is sponsored by established
titles a fun and novel way to preserve
the natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
establish titles lets you call yourself
a lady Lord or a lad due to a
traditional Scottish custom you see
landowners used to refer to themselves
as this and established titles allows
you to buy at least one square foot of
dedicated land and a private estate in
edleston Scotland on top of this it's a
great way to help out the environment
women as established titles or planetary
with every single order they work with
global Charities like one tree planet
and trees for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst also helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes with a bit of an ego
boost on top of all this environmental
stuff you can officially change your
name on credit cards plane tickets your
dating profile whatever you want they
also give you a certificate confirming
your Lord's ship and a unique plot
Number that confirms your exact plot of
land but before Kevin spoilers you punk
I am the Lord of this realm now in
addition to this established titles have
also told me that the first 200 people
who use my link in the description below
will be given a plot within walking
distance of mine it makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code heavy spoilers you get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com heavy spoilers to get your
gifts now and help some support the
channel thanks now according to the
leaks Cassie is apparently captured by
Kang and she's held hostage so that
Scott will do a heist to fix his machine
Kang hints that he's killed several
versions of the Avengers before and he
brings up Thor he apparently asks if
Scott is the one with a hammer and Scott
jokes are people confuse him with Thor
all the time which it actually happens
with me I get called Chris Hemsworth now
Kang also warns that if he doesn't help
then other versions of him will invade
their reality and end up destroying it
at this point Scott starts to carry out
his job and he apparently goes into the
quantum Nexus another reason why I think
this partly checks out is that it
mentions him running into several
versions of himself down there which we
do see in the trailer there's the big
giant man running alongside him and
we'll meet Scots from several different
universes I'll be one from a universe
where he never got fired from Baskin and
Robbins because only in the infinite
Multiverse do they not find out this
version is going to have no clue about
what's going on and he'll be a sort of
comic relief well all of them are comic
reliefs but you know what I mean now
there'll also be a fight against Murdoch
but they'll plead with him to save the
world Kang will start to bring together
his forces and we'll see his huge Army
he tells Janet that the final Universe
he conquests will be hers and he starts
up his machine he brutally attacks
Murdoch which leaves him in critical
condition the group rushed to his side
and they say he died in Avenger before
he passes away there's a massive battle
that's supposed to be similar to the
ending of Aquaman with Hank riding a
legion of ants in and US seeing lots of
different creatures coming together to
stop Kang's forces we're also meant to
be getting new suits for this too with
Scott getting a black one whilst hopes
wings are sort of like lightsabers once
the forces are defeated the leaves Kang
and he sends Janet Hank Cassie and hope
back to normal sized World whilst he
kicks the crap out of Scott he smashes
him like it's the like button but hope
returns back into the quantum realm and
they almost managed to trap him however
he escapes and leaves Scott home
substranded much like how Kang was at
the start of the movie he of course
threatened to conquer Janet's Universe
last and therefore it explains the gap
between this and Kang Dynasty however it
is very much setting up that movie which
will of course be the next Avengers one
after this what about Kang is rumored to
appear in other films along the way he
just won't be the main antagonist like
he is here on the surface Hank Janet and
Cassie make a promise to find them and
in the quantum realm we see Scott and
hope together saying they trust them to
locate them this leads into the
post-creative scene which is apparently
basically just Cassie looking over
computer screens searching for where
they are she will apparently come across
something and get a shock which is when
we cut to Black we won't see what this
is and it'll not be revealed with it
being a big Ralph boner level [ __ ] tease
anyway that sums up the leaks that we
have and basically the movie is going to
be used as a stepping stone to introduce
Kank properly then have him go often in
the Multiverse to who knows where it's
also rumored that we'll be getting other
versions of Kang in the MCU but the one
that we Face Off against in Dynasty and
Secret Wars will be the same one that we
Face here Secret Wars is gonna be a
major event and I've Heard lots of
rumors about how it ties in a Toby
Andrew Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds
everyone basically returning down the
line I am thinking of doing a video on
it at some point but let me know below
if you want to see that or not anyway I
think the movie sounds really solid and
this will probably end up being the best
Ant-Man film I love the first one but
the second I thought was pretty poor but
this sounds like it's gonna be the best
and biggest or smallest now I'm really
looking forward to Kang shaking up the
MCU in a Jonathan Majors way and with
him spanning several faces I am
expecting something special from him
anyway that wraps up the plot leak
breakdown and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the film do you think
the leaks are legit do you think Kang
will live up to his potential comment
below and let me know we are an
incompetition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of nov that and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the leaks we
make the comments at random on the 15th
and the winners of the last one are on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch make
sure you check out one of our house of
the Dragon breakdowns which will be
linked on screen right now having a lot
of fun talking about the show especially
now it's over not a mad rush to get
things out at 2AM in the morning so yeah
having fun with it and I hope you are
too hopefully I see you around one of
those videos but if not enjoy the rest
of your week take care peace